La respuesta de los aliados a la invasión
rusa de Ucrania ha sido muy clara:
Por un lado han apoyado al gobierno de Zelensky
con toneladas de armas y dinero.
Por otro lado han castigado a Rusia con un
montón de sanciones económicas de todo tipo:
Desde la prohibición de que los barcos y
los aviones rusos usen los puertos y aeropuertos
occidentales, hasta la prohibición de suministrarles
un montón de productos de todo tipo.
Hablamos de uno de los programas de sanciones
más grandes jamás llevados a cabo.
Os hemos hablado de ello tanto en el boletín
de Patreon como en pasados vídeos.
El caso es que el apoyo a Ucrania ha sido
todo un éxito: el gobierno ucraniano ha conseguido
resistir la embestida rusa e incluso darle
la vuelta a la tortilla y tomar la iniciativa.
Pero, ¿Qué ha ocurrido con la segunda parte
de la respuesta occidental?
¿Qué está ocurriendo con las sanciones
a Rusia?
¿Hasta qué punto han debilitado la economía
de este país?
¿Están siendo un éxito o un fracaso?
Bien, teniendo en cuenta todas las sanciones
rápidamente se creó una expectativa: que
la economía rusa se vendría abajo y el país
colapsaría.
Sin embargo, terminado el 2022 la situación
parecía muy diferente.
Sí, el país entró en recesión, pero apenas
se dejó un 2,5%.
Y lo que es aún peor, los ingresos del gobierno
ni siquiera se resintieron.
De hecho, pese a todas las sanciones, en 2022
los ingresos de Rusia por la exportación
de hidrocarburos se dispararon.
Fijaos.
N1 (Los ingresos de Rusia por las ventas de
petróleo y gas aumentaron casi un tercio
durante el año.
Kommersant)
Por volumen las exportaciones de gas cayeron,
pero Rusia exportó más petróleo y más
gas natural licuado que los años anteriores…
Y además todo lo vendió a precios mucho
más altos.
Lejos de hacerle hincar la rodilla, da la
sensación de que las sanciones hicieron fluir
el dinero hacía Rusia como si no hubiera
mañana.
Financiar así la guerra de Ucrania era pan
comido.
Al menos eso es lo que parecen indicarnos
los datos.
Por ejemplo, fijaos qué ocurrió en 2022
con el saldo por cuenta corriente de la balanza
de pagos, que es donde se mide el resultado
del intercambio de bienes, servicios e inversiones
con el extranjero.
Como podéis comprobar, Rusia tuvo un superávit
de casi 250 mil millones de dólares.
Mucho más que el año anterior.
De esta forma, en apenas unos pocos meses
Rusia pudo compensar cerca de dos terceras
partes de todas las reservas extranjeras que
las potencias occidentales le congelaron a
este país.
¿Os acordáis?
N2(28 de febrero de 2022: El G-7 ha congelado
todos los activos de las reservas rusas en
sus países.)
Y es que, de hecho, todo apunta a que tanto
el petróleo como el gas jugaron un papel
clave en la decisión final de Putin de invadir
Ucrania.
¿Por qué?
Pues veréis, bajo la perspectiva del Kremlin
la enorme dependencia europea de los hidrocarburos
rusos haría que la respuesta occidetal fuera
muy comedida.
Que es, exactamente, lo que ocurrió cuando
se anexionó Crimea en el año 2014.
Y en cualquier caso la propia tensión de
la guerra elevaría el precio de venta de
los hidrocarburos, lo que le permitiría al
gobierno ruso financiar sin mayor inconveniente
la guerra de Ucrania.
Digamos que la guerra se podría pagar sola.
Y en cierto modo, lo hemos visto, eso es lo
que pasó.
Esta es una de las pocas veces en toda esta
historia que el cálculo del Kremlin parece
que fue correcto…
Al menos por ahora.
Queridos amigos, amigas, ¿Cómo está la
economía rusa?
¿Qué perspectivas tiene de cara al futuro?
¿Realmente es inmune a las sanciones occidentales?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
Y lo primero de todo es empezar la casa por
los cimientos.
Tenemos que saber dónde estamos exactamente.
Atentos.
T1 (LA CARA B DE LAS CUENTAS RUSAS)
Lo primero que tenemos que tener presente
para que no nos vendan el pollino es que hablamos
de Rusia….
Que no es el país más transparente ni tiene,
precisamente, el gobierno más honesto del
mundo.
En 2022 el Kremlin introdujo la censura estadística:
una enorme cantidad de datos como las reservas
internacionales o las métricas comerciales
o de producción dejaron de estar disponibles.
También se limitaron los informes financieros,
incluso los de los bancos privados.
Evidentemente a ningún gobierno le gusta
airear datos que pueden no ir bien, y mucho
menos a un gobierno tan autoritario como el
de Putin.
(Además, los fuertes controles de capitales
que se han establecido en el país han hecho
que el rublo no refleje realmente su valor
de mercado.
¿Y por qué es esto importante?
Pues porque para valorar el estado real de
la economía hace falta una tasa de cambio
de mercado.
De otra forma el valor internacional del PIB
y su capacidad de compra se adultera.)
Por si eso fuera poco, la producción militar
también contribuye positivamente al PIB,
incluso aunque no valga para nada.
Por ejemplo, si se producen obuses de artillería,
se envían al frente y se lanzan…
Los obuses desaparecen pero quedan incluidos
como valor añadido en el PIB.
Y sí, es verdad que es algo que se ha producido
en el año…
Pero es algo que sin embargo no supone un
incremento de la riqueza nacional.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Si algo está creciendo en Rusia es precisamente
el gasto militar.
Así que mucho ojo con las estadísticas rusas
y la creatividad
Pero, vale, ya sé lo que muchos seguramente
estéis pensando….
Y dale, ya están otra vez los de Visualpolitik
arremetiendo contra Rusia a base de cuestio
nar los datos de este país.
[Pues hombre, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Hablamos de Rusia…
Lo malo sería no cuestionar sus datos.]
Pero, ¿sabéis qué?
Incluso dándolos por buenos las cosas no
van tan bien para el Kremlin como muchos piensan.
(Primero porque Rusia es un país que lleva
años en declive.
Hablamos de un país de 143 millones de habitantes
cuyo PIB equivale al de Italia y sus exportaciones
a las de Bélgica, y eso a pesar de todo el
petróleo, el gas y demás recursos naturales.
Pero eso ni siquiera es todo.
Hablamos de un país muy envejecido cuya población
se ha venido contrayendo desde la caída de
la Unión Soviética.
Hablamos de un país que lleva años en crisis
y cuyo nivel de vida se ha reducido durante
la última década.)
Pues bien, ahora si las sanciones han hecho
algo ha sido precisamente acelerar esa tendencia.
Por ejemplo, fijaos en este gráfico.
Los datos del FMI y el Banco Mundial - que
por otra parte se aproximan mucho a las propias
previsiones del gobierno ruso - son claros:
en apenas dos años tras la invasión de Ucrania
la economía rusa retrocederá entre un 5
y un 8%.
Y, ojo, porque se suponía que en 2022 la
economía rusa crecería un 3%.
Es decir, que el daño ya causado por las
sanciones tras la invasión de Ucrania es
mucho mayor de lo parece a simple vista.
Podemos estar hablando tranquilamente de un
golpe de entre un 8 y un 12% en dos años.
Podemos debatir mucho, pero este es el coste
real para el nivel de vida de la población
rusa que ya están teniendo las sanciones.
Y eso a pesar de los precios récord de la
energía.
Pero es que, además, tenemos que tener en
cuenta que las sanciones tenían fundamentalmente
3 objetivos:
Primero, castigar la capacidad productiva
de Rusia a largo plazo para limitar sus recursos
y condenarlo a la irrelevancia.
Segundo, obstaculizar el esfuerzo de guerra
y dañar la industria militar.
Por ejemplo, impidiendo que puedan suministrar
a sus tropas en el frente con armas modernas
y eficaces.
Y tercero, cortar los lazos energéticos y
financieros de Rusia con occidente.
Y sobre todo con Europa.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Esos 3 objetivos en gran medida ya se han
cumplido.
Desde el punto de vista económico, las sanciones
están castigando a Rusia.
En un próximo vídeo de Si lo Hubiera Sabido
os daremos todos los detalles sobre esta cuestión
en concreto: os hablaremos del impacto que
la guerra y las sanciones están teniendo
en el comercio, en la industria, en la huida
de talento y en la propia política monetaria
del banco central ruso.
Así que si aún no seguís este canal no
perdáis más tiempo porque además habrá
sorpresas pronto.
Ya sabéis, tenéis el enlace en la descripción.
De momento ya os adelanto que el gobierno
de Estados Unidos espera que el coste para
la economía rusa de las sanciones en 2030
sea como mínimo del 20% del PIB.
Un 20% sobre un país que ya estaba en declive.
La diferencia entre Rusia y los países occidentales
no dejará de crecer.
Primer objetivo cumplido.
Desde el punto de vista militar, ¿qué queréis
que os diga?
La industria militar rusa está perdiendo
contrat os por todo el mundo y su capacidad
para producir cosas relativamente modernas
está muy mermada.
De hecho, eso es lo que explica cosas como
estas:
C1(“Tenemos informes de los ucranianos de
que cuando encuentran equipos militares rusos,
están llenos de semiconductores que sacaron
de lavavajillas y neveras”
Gina Raimondo, secretaria de comercio de Estados
Unidos.)
Segundo objetivo cumplido.
Y en tercer lugar, tanto si hablamos de petróleo
como de gas, la ruptura energética de Europa
con Rusia ya es un hecho.
N4 (Borrell anunció la superación de la
dependencia energética de la UE hacía Rusia.
KOMMERSANT)
Ya lo veis.
Las sanciones internacionales no han conseguido
parar la guerra de Ucrania ni tampoco han
hecho colapsar la economía rusa, pero mucho
ojo con pensar que no han servido para nada.
Además, fijaos en este gráfico y luego añadirle
la fuga de cerebros, la salida de empresas,
la huida de capitales o el a islamiento internacional.
Las cosas en Rusia, amigos, no van nada bien.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué?
Eso ni siquiera es lo peor.
Lo peor es lo que puede estar por llegar.
Prestad atención a esta declaración:
C2(“Con los ingresos astronómicos en petróleo
y gas, en general, los ingresos presupuestarios
aumentaron solo un 10%, y los gastos en más
del 20%.
Esto indica que la situación con las finanzas
públicas se está deteriorando y puede volverse
crítica durante el 2023.
Nikolai Korzhenevsky, economista, fundador
de Sberindex.)
El Kremlin obtuvo en 2022 unos ingresos récord
por la venta de hidrocarburos.
Pese a ello, las cuentas públicas han entrado
en números rojos…
De hecho, tanto es así que por ejemplo el
gobierno ruso ya ha empezado a recortar partidas
que hasta hace poco consideraban estratégicas.
Por ejemplo, si en 2019 habían proyectado
invertir 56.800 millones de rublos hasta el
2024 para el desarrollo de la inteligencia
artificial.
Ahora los números han cambiado: serán 24.600
millones hasta el año 2030.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Qué puede ocurrir entonces
si los ingresos extraordinarios del gas y
el petróleo desaparecen?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, mucho ojo,
porque justo ahí es donde ahora están apuntando
los aliados de Ucrania.
¡Atentos!
T2 (EL ARMAGGEDON ENERGÉTICO PARA RUSIA)
El gobierno ruso es terriblemente dependiente
de los ingresos del petróleo y del gas.
Antes de la guerra este sector generaba casi
el 45% de todos los ingresos del gobierno
al tiempo que generaba todas las divisas extranjeras
necesarias para cubrir las importaciones.
¿A quién le vendían?
Pues, digamos que Europa era con mucha diferencia
su principal cliente.
Esta región se tragaba en torno al 60% de
todas las exportaciones de hidrocarburos de
Rusia.
Estados Unidos también era un comprador importante.
Ahora las sanciones han puesto patas arriba
este mercado.
(Con el paso de los meses Estados Unidos,
el Reino Unido, la Unión Europea y algunos
otros aliados han prohibido o comenzado a
restringir las importaciones de petróleo
y de gas desde Rusia.
Pero desde luego la medida más contundente
llegó en diciembre de 2022, concretamente
el día 5.
Ese día entró en vigor el tope al precio
del petróleo ruso.
El último mecanismo ideado por los aliados
de Ucrania para castigar a Rusia exactamente
dónde más le duele.
Estos países han dejado o están dejando
de comprar petróleo ruso.
Y tampoco compran ya apenas gas, pero eso
no ha sido suficiente.
Con el tope al precio del petróleo ruso le
prohíben a cualquier empresa occidental que
preste servicios en una operación que esté
relacionada con la venta de crudo ruso por
encima del tope fijado.
De entrada 60 dólares el barril.
Hablamos de servicios de todo tipo: desde
el transporte, a los seguros pasando por la
financiación de las compras.)
Y aún más, a comienzos de febrero está
medida se extenderá a los productos refinados,
esto es al diesel y la gasolina.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Cómo están funcionando
todas estas medidas?
Pues…
Fijaos.
C3("La prohibición del petróleo de la UE
y el límite de precios del petróleo finalmente
han entrado en acción y el impacto es tan
significativo como se esperaba".
Lauri Myllyvirta, analista principal de CREA.)
El hecho de que los países occidentales estén
dejando de comprarle petróleo y gas a Rusia
ha hecho que este país tenga que mirar desesperadamente
a otros mercados como China o la India.
El problema es que llevar el petróleo y el
gas a estos países es más caro que proveer
a Europa y además están las sanciones…
Para cubrirse los compradores chinos e indios
entre otros le están exigiendo fortísimos
descuentos a Rusia.
Concretamente desde que entró en vigor el
tope al precio del petróleo, el crudo de
los Urales, el crudo de referencia de Rusia
se está vendiendo en el entorno de los 50
dólares el barril.
Por si fuera poco, las compras de estos países
no están consiguiendo ni de lejos compensar
la pérdida del mercado europeo.
Según los cálculos del Centro de Investigación
sobre Energía y Aire Limpio, un think tank
con sede en Helsinki, en 2023 Rusia puede
perder 280 millones de dólares diarios como
consecuencia del precio del crudo y sus derivados.
Y, ojo, que no hablamos de un futurible poco
probable.
Actualmente Rusia ya estaría perdiendo 172
millones de dólares cada día.
Hablamos de que en términos anuales las pérdidas
para Rusia pueden rondar los 100 mil millones
de dólares.
En esta tabla del propio Ministerio de Hacienda
de Rusia podéis ver cómo evolucionan aproximadamente
los ingresos del gobierno ante diferentes
escenarios de producción y precio.
(Es verdad que en el pasado el petróleo ya
ha cotizado a precios de 50 e incluso 40 dólares
el barril y Rusia lo ha soportado.
El problema es que hoy existen dos grandes
diferencias:
Por un lado, cuando se dio esa situación
el gobierno recortó el gasto público.
El problema es que ahora la guerra de Ucrania
le obliga a incrementarlo al tiempo que los
ingresos no petroleros también están cayendo
con fuerza.
Y en segundo lugar, ahora por culpa de las
sanciones Rusia va a vender mucho menos al
extranjero.
Así que mucho ojo con esta especie de trampa
en la que se está metiendo Moscú.)
Además, no solo hablamos del petróleo.
Lo mismo ocurre con el gas.
Pero…
¿Queréis un dato oficial?
Pues veréis, en términos de volumen, por
ejemplo, las ventas internacionales de gas
de Gazprom cayeron en 2022 un 46%.
La compañía compensó está caída con los
mayores precios, pero claro…
si tenemos en cuenta los nuevos precios del
gas el cañón presupuestario para Rusia puede
ser más que considerable.
C4("Rusia sigue siendo una potencia energética,
pero su papel ha cambiado drásticamente.
Rusia tendrá una menor cuota de mercado en
petróleo y gas, obtendrá menos beneficios
y también ha perdido parte de su apalancamiento
geopolítico".
Vladimir Milov, ex viceministro de energía
ruso)
Queridos amigos, amigas, las sanciones quizás
no hayan hecho colapsar la economía rusa,
pero han cumplido objetivos muy importantes
que le causarán mucho daño a Rusia durante
los próximos años.
Además, las nuevas sanciones sobre el petróleo
pueden provocar un escenario económico mucho
más complicado tanto para Rusia como para
el propio Kremlin.
Putin ha conseguido un tanto personal: pasar
a la historia como uno de los líderes rusos
que más riqueza destruyó en menos tiempo.
Por si fuera poco ahora en Rusia han comenzado
a surgir voces en favor de regresar a la planificación
central y el control del estado.
Suena mal decirlo pero en Washington se están
frotando las manos.
Rusia está perdiendo en el terreno militar,
en el terreno energético y también puede
terminar perdiendo en el terreno económico.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Crees que Rusia podrá soportar las nuevas
sanciones?
¿Qué crees que hará el Kremlin para capear
el temporal?
¿Será suficiente para que estén dispuestos
a terminar con la guerra en Ucrania?
¿Qué echas en falta?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.